i'm really impressed that nobody got
injured like yeah yeah because i agree
yeah there's six of us i mean did you
guys take any bad tumbles during uh yeah
i let's just say i'm really glad i
rented out a helmet because
i think about 80 of my falls involved me
just my head just getting [ __ ]
whiplash back right
you like kill a toddler
i almost did i i
i because like like on the first like
two three days i didn't know how to stop
so my my technique for stopping uh
involved falling over um and if i didn't
fall over i would just basically just
take out whoever like was in front of me
this is this great photo that luke took
of you just like there's this kid right
here and then there's just gaunt
menacingly behind me like i'm about to
destroy you
move out of the way so i must have
decked at least like three kids on the
slope for like the first three days oh
my god god
the kid killer thank god no one got
injured except for those three years
yeah another bus
like it was because it was like a
competition because like
me and luke just kept [ __ ] crashing
into each other in the first two days
because we had zero control yeah we
didn't know how to control our balls
right and i remember
luke decked joey yeah [ __ ] legs
sweeped me i had a great pov of this i
was like really i was gonna i was my i
was like leading everyone down the right
slopes
and then i was waiting for them at the
bottom and i saw joey just slowly like
going down like this
yeah and then out of nowhere like rko i
just see our friend luke who doesn't
know how to stop she's coming coming and
i see jerry
and i'm like i'm about getting my
popcorn out
just waiting for this to happen i think
joey's going joey's going it doesn't
move his head at all and then suddenly
he just goes doom
right in the back of his legs and joey
just flips over like i'm so funny
because all i heard was i was i was i
was slowly going down because it was
kind of a narrow stretch and also i was
waiting for luke right yeah so i was
slowly going down because i saw you guys
there and i i remember specifically
behind me i could hear luke in the
distance going sorry sorry sorry i'm
sorry it's just getting louder and
louder and louder but i thought he was
saying that to other people right that
were behind me yeah so i was like oh
luke you know it's silly here silly hips
it gets louder sorry sorry sorry and
then just bam
right in the back of my knees
i should have been more concerned but it
was so funny i wish you had filmed that
yeah
by the time i realized it was happening
was like five seconds
i couldn't get my phone out but i wish i
did i wanted to see it
yeah i was too busy like falling over
myself to really see what everyone else
was like falling over over because i
remember i had a few bad tumbles but
actually like some of the worst tumbles
was when i was just actually not going
the fastest it was like because when you
go fast sometimes like you saw you guys
saw me do have some pretty big fours
where i did like a [ __ ] triple
backflip or whatever yeah or whatever
but to me those falls are fine because
you take the momentum and then you just
like literally roll with it right and
you hardly feel it some of the worst
falls i had was
on like the second day because you saw
this one yeah these guys were trying to
like warn me not to stop myself with my
hands right because sometimes if you
have a bad phone you stop yourself with
your hands you uh could break your wrist
you could snap your wrist or break your
arm or something so they were telling me
uh you gotta you gotta fall on your arms
you gotta do this make sure make sure
you don't try to catch yourself you
gotta do this i need like like this
right and i took that as i'm going to do
this
right
not realizing the mistake i was about uh
to encounter because what happened is i
had a like i was taking a bunch of
tumbles i was like this doesn't hurt i'm
a [ __ ] pro at falling over with a
with a snowboard so there's one time i
was going down this really like this
this this the slope wasn't stupid i was
getting pretty slowly but i just catch
the edge and i'm about to fall straight
to my face so i do what they tell me and
i tuck my arms in
unfortunately my fists were right in
front of my face right so what happens
is i fall on my arm and i just [ __ ]
deck my stomach in the face
i just go
what
and i remember
i fall over and you know
like you know when you have a bad four
and you just gotta like lay there yeah
just question life for a bit that's when
you know it's bad yeah yeah and i
remember i lay there for a few seconds
and i just hear kind of going
right go on
because i just saw this like because
obviously it looks like ants in the
background i just can't just fall on his
face and i was like get back up
get back
get back up and then he didn't get up
but i'm like oh no he hurt himself
that was like it was a couple of times
like like on the last day i think where
you did that like triple backflip right
oh yeah i saw it in the distance and i
was like oh that that that looked like
it hurt and then god just did a move for
about 20 seconds i was like oh he's dead
he's straight up dead
yeah never seen that one i just saw like
someone doing like flips but not good i
could hear the ssx music playing when
that was happening
he took so many falls i did i did
i i think that's when i learned the most
though when you when you do take the
falls it's not about how many times you
get hit down it's how you get how many
times you get back
yeah that's about the drive it's
actually like the most embarrassing fall
i took wasn't even on the slopes it was
on the ski lift
oh yeah
yeah because uh well joey was there
because uh me and joey were trying to
get on the ski lift together like two
main skates so two it was a yeah it was
a two-man ski lift so me and joey line
up together so we're just gonna have a
nice chill right up on the mountain and
so i look back i've done the skeeter for
a bunch of times so i'm not even a
beginner anymore i'm like
i i like know how to get on the ski lift
right so so you think it is
it is a lot harder on a snowboard than a
ski yeah also i thought because i just
so i'm standing there waiting for the
ski lift to come around i look back and
in my mind i take a mental note of the
momentum
of this ski lift right so i know how
fast this thing's going yeah and so
right before
uh it gets to uh it gets near us i turn
around thinking it's gonna have the same
momentum not thinking that they're gonna
slow down slow it down for us
so what i do is i turn around and i just
sit
and you know that feeling where you take
a step where you think there's like a
stare yeah and then there's just not
so i just
i had that i i had that feeling where i
sit down
and i just feel nothing and i'm like oh
no and like i just i just collapsed yeah
yeah and then the next thing i notice is
i feel like the [ __ ] bump on the back
of my helmet which thank god i was
wearing a helmet at this point yeah and
so i'm just like they're gonna stop the
ski lift so my instinct uh is just to
adopt the fetal position while while
they hopefully stop the ski lift
plot twist they don't stop the ski lift
and so the ski lift just goes over me
and joey just like joey i guess just
snowboards over me because i look at
yeah i look up thinking what the [ __ ]
happening and i just see joey just
looking back on the skeeling feeling
right you're right [ __ ]
it was because it was amazing because
like i'm surprised they didn't stop it
they said yeah they showed that right
because like because how i usually do it
with like skis or snowboards is i wait
for the the chair to physically hit me
in the back of the knees so that's where
i know oh it's right underneath kind of
like bend over yeah just get my butt
ready so i was i was doing that i was
looking back you know just waiting
waiting waiting waiting until it hits me
right here and then i look over look up
sit down thinking it's all good and then
i i hear like this horrible scraping
sound from somewhere i was like what's
what's going on i look over and god's
just down there
under the thing just like
this and i was like oh they're going to
stop it they don't stop it it's right
over gun i was like all right that's
cruel
and then they finally stop it after
it's gone past you yeah yeah and the
woman comes over being like you're all
right i'm like what do you mean you're
all right yeah you should have stopped
why did you why did you check up on him
after you left the chair
it's like it's like watching a fight
with the teachers like watching the kids
when it's over like oh you guys sorry i
was like i'll i'll wait for them to
throw a few yeah i'll break it up break
it up let's bring it up here
well that was the most embarrassing one
because they're just like everyone was
just obviously staring at me i stopped
the entire ski lift and
yeah that's just just like social
anxiety up through the roof because i'm
just like it happens yeah i know it
happens they can't see your face yeah
that's true that's true you're
completely topped up yeah who cares yeah
aside from that had a [ __ ] wonderful
time uh my body hurt a lot but yeah it
was worth it i'm i'm like just wearing
i'm wearing to go again honestly it's
probably like some of the best snow i've
ever snowboarded or skied on my life
this is amazing how is it compared to
like european ski resorts um i think i
like european ones more there's normally
they're normally bigger way more like
options but i mean it was the quality of
snow was insane it was so good powder
it's it powdered snowed like so like two
meters a day or something yeah yeah so
most of the black slopes weren't like
groomed so we went on one and it was
literally just like i was like on a yeah
and i fell over on one of them because
it's just too deep and it's so hard to
turn and it was really bad because i
basically just shoveled a [ __ ] ton of
snow into my jacket and pants
and i was freezing and i was like in the
cold of my my hand trying to scoop this
out
minus 15 trying to get all the snare
because if you just leave it in it'll
just melt and then you'll be wet yeah it
doesn't even wash the world try to get
it out like [ __ ] [ __ ] and then i had to
like ski for another hour my my ass was
completely numb
i couldn't feel anything it was so bad
and i was i when i got back to the room
i was like i can't i can't feel my ass
it's been numb for like a good two hours
someone could have smacked my ass i'm
gonna know that clip is definitely gonna
be taking out
doing too much riding on the board
it's so good though it was really cool
there's really good ski resorts i want
to go back
in the ash to get to but good
yeah i think if i if i go there again
i'd probably want to like
go to sapporo for a bit or something
yeah and then go there i think i think
that's what like a lot of uh tourists do
is they're like kind of maybe dedicate
like a week or two for like the whole
thing because it is kind of out of the
way especially if you're coming from
tokyo is a really fun city yeah as far
as grace is a really chill city like all
i wanted to do on this ski trip was just
get the basics down for my snowboarding
and i think i managed to do that
yeah so now i'm like more confident
thank you came along very well
improved a lot but uh yeah now i'm just
ready to like tear it down with the boys
for real hopefully and i'll try and try
and keep up with them the real ssx
trickies
i want everyone to get better so that
then chris feels obliged
but he has no choice because no one
wants to do greens anymore yeah i mean
we accidentally went down a reds on our
second day like like we just said didn't
go amazing but we made it down didn't go
amazing uh but we survived that's the
important thing yeah there was like
there was this um
basically there was this tiny little and
little little sign that was like go this
way if you want to go back to where you
came from on a green yeah and if you go
down straight which is like the whole
thing you know you wouldn't it's really
hard to see this thing because it also
goes back in on itself yeah so the slope
goes down this way and there's a little
cut off here where it goes down and back
around and then joins off to like
another mountain it's impossible to see
considering the entire thing is white
the conditions are really bad so just
everything just blends in and then i was
last cause i was making sure everyone
was all right and then i i was like oh
no the
luke who i was with at the time because
i'm pretty sure he was last he went down
the red and i was like oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
moments before a disaster yeah he just
went down the red
and i was like
and then i'm like oh my god they've all
gone down the green and then we're stuck
here and it's like lunch time yeah yeah
and we was already it was like 1 1 30
and i was like we probably would be
eating by now like we're [ __ ] because
we want to go meet have lunch with them
as well so how do we get back like but
then luckily all these [ __ ] idiots
went down the red as well turns out we
all missed it
so we all met up yeah yeah but then the
screen was really annoying as well
because it was like you had it was like
a flat really really flat and i told the
guys i was like guys you got to make
sure you get as much speed as you can on
your snowboards yeah like walk anywhere
we're like got it put snowboards on two
seconds later falls on our ass all right
taking it
yeah so i'm going as fast as i can as i
can i'm like getting low to the ground
like get out of aerodynamics i get i get
over there and i'm like oh my god i made
it all right nice i'm waiting i'm like
they'll come any second now like 10
minutes later they come around the
corner walking
and i was like what is this
okay to be fair we did
we did attempt to snowboard to to me it
wasn't a case of getting to the end to
me it was a case of how far can i get
before i fall over because like i knew
once i fought i fell over that was it
momentum was going i gotta take off my
[ __ ] it is hard to
uh go fast on a snowball much easier on
skis um i don't know i i just kind of
again i like i was like i'm i'm all
self-taught with it yeah so i just you
just kind of get a feeling for it oh
yeah sure yeah by the end of the week we
all i think definitely got a feeling for
it go fast go fast i mean we were going
a hell of a lot faster on the last day
compared to the first day that's true
like god was [ __ ] blitzing down this
mountain and i was like oh god he's
about to ssx tricky right now i could
feel it
yeah well we had to get back to like
arsky resort
and
the they closed their like way of
getting over yeah yeah
what would you call the what's the not
the british
it's like a pathway what's there's a
word for this right a pathway no not a
pathway slalom
there's a i've got the word i forgot
what it was there's a word for like an
entrance
that is like a i don't know
um
you're literally using all the words i
know i know so there's a path right and
it closes at like 3 30. so we had so i i
was like [ __ ] okay if you don't go back
over as well you have to get like a
30-40 minute bus ride yeah yeah and i'd
i'd rather kill myself to get a bus
it's just so depressing when you've got
your ski gear yeah yeah you got to sit
on this bus it's like oh no i why would
i do that when i can ski back right yeah
i'm not so i
me and ohara were going to go back over
and then we asked the guys we're like
are you guys coming and they're like ah
no we'll get we'll get the bus because
it was like kind of tough we had to ski
a bunch
quickly get on a chair lift ski over
then walk over and then ski back down it
is kind of difficult especially if
you're tired right yeah yeah yeah and
they weren't doing it and i was like all
right no worries we'll do it we'll do it
so we were going and then right before
we were about to cross it they they
called us and they were like oh yeah
actually we'll we'll do it i think we
can do it yeah run like oh [ __ ] it's
like mission impossible
get these boys
ryan back to the hotel we've got to get
them back over so we had to quickly like
rush these guys and we were like no
falling just go don't don't stop just
just be good
yeah because they shut it off at 3 30
for some reason i don't know why it's
just 3 30 the the sun [ __ ] sets so
you just can't see anything especially
up there like even during the day the
visibility was so bad right it was
pretty bad yeah yeah i definitely
understand why people snow and ski board
from this trip though especially on the
last day where the visibility was clear
and i just kind of realized oh
snowboarding and skiing is just hiking
but the fun part
right because you're going down yeah go
go you got the you get like the amazing
view but you don't have to put in the
effort of like getting that amazing view
isn't it crazy when you like you're on
the ground and you look up at the
mountain and you see us steep some of
these things yeah yeah yeah and you're
like [ __ ] i i skied down there i
snowballed down there it's crazy yeah
because i remember on the first day when
we stayed on the beginner slope so the
beginner slope had this ski lift to take
us up the beginning slope and
taking us up because it was so slow it
took us like what 15 minutes i think
yeah it's like 10 10 10 15 minutes so in
my mind i'm like oh we're going up like
half the mountain holy [ __ ] and then i
remember on the second day when conor
was like oh yeah we're gonna go to the
top of the mountain today and i'm like
cool where was the beginner slope and he
points to this point which is like a
tenth of the way up the mountain and
you're like
what
you mean you mean we were this low
but the view was so good it was already
amazing what's going on
10 out of 10 would uh recommend skiing
to uh anyone who like me as a kid one
wasn't able to go and uh especially if
you're from a southeast asian country
john is a white man now
unfortunately it just happens to be like
the most expensive
vacation sport you can do yeah but it is
good it's really good you know you can
do budget ones
plenty of like budget packages that i
know that we used to do when i was like
yeah yeah japan definitely has those as
well yeah for sure
like the all-inclusive thing